the LSU Tigers at three no they are
fired up in the state of Louisiana and
the coach himself is here on the Rich
Eisen show fresh off the last second win
at Auburn coach Edwards you're on how
are you coach do a great rest great show
great to be with you too what does this
win mean for you you want a small team
and guys that work very hard we have a
tremendous amount of great leadership we
want a team I have some tremendous
assistant coaches a big win for the
Tigers but we have to take it one at a
time and get prepared for Louisiana Tech
this week what's the story behind your
kicker how did you first meet him where
him meet you well you know we needed to
kick her and extra great McMahon on
special teams goes to go out and find
the best graduate transfer available he
did his research and we found Cole and
we're glad we have him he's an
outstanding young man a great kicker kid
from Massachusetts right there he's from
yes sir he's originally from California
out there there are thousand oaks it's
an amazing kid from Thousand Oaks by way
of Massachusetts is now a hero in the
state of little gumbo and having fun I
mean and it seems to me from you okay
that and just watching you in the team
that it's do you stress having fun to
these kids
questions yes I want our guys to enjoy
coming to work on our coaches enjoy
coming to work work hard but really we
have a nice family type atmosphere here
we have played with a lot of energy we
practice with a lot of energy that's
part of our program and beating Miami in
week one what did that you know I know
you say one at a time but I mean that
that was one of those moments where I
think you served notice on a whole bunch
of people coach would you agree with
that yes he gave us some confidence you
know score 20 points on them good Miami
defense in the second quarter of
establish a running game in Nick bro set
for Joe burrows to go out there when his
first game bought defense to play the
way did and then Colt racing make this
tremendous kick so a lot of new guys a
lot of new faces perform very well that
game and now what about the SEC season
are you what are you stressing to these
kids I know you've got a game against
Louisiana Tech next but then you got a
whole bunch of big-time teams including
Georgia
Alabama on your schedule coach we need
to improve we need to improve every day
there's a lot of things to improve every
week we're gonna have a great tell the
truth money today get after take it one
day at a time and focus on individual
improvement every day much what do you
tell Barrow what do you tell your
quarterback again there's a lot of
things to get better at obviously you
missed some throws this or some open
throw some open reach keep on doing the
thing he's doing I'm so proud of our
offensive line they gave up zero sacks
against one of the best offensive minds
in the country so we made some progress
in that area
Edwards you're on LSU head coach here in
the Rich Eisen show are you aware you
made a state police officer very famous
at the end of that game he's well he's
my buddy I don't I don't know what
happened but Reggie is my buddy you me
get my shot oh is that good man give me
give him a shout-out who's that guy that
was to your right there code name is
Reggie and he's a good friend of mine
and he come see us on a daily basis he's
a great young men okay and what'd you
say to him can you repeat oh I don't
remember what you were saying to that
state those are the ball but we'll havin
fun so you're you're in the zone is what
you're saying you're in the zone in the
zone I love getting that rich and now
what what does it mean for you and your
family okay because everybody who can
just hear every single moment you open
your mouth that you are from Louisiana
what does it mean to you a lot it's uh
it's something that always water is a
young man means a lot to represent the
state of Louisiana I understand how
important LSU is to the state of
Louisiana and I much pride to people
having LSU I've always wanted to be here
obviously had some great times at Miami
and USC but this was a job that always
wanted and thank God that I got it now I
got to do something with it and I
understand the expectations are very
high but I have the same expectations on
myself and my staff and John
what would the kid who always wanted to
be head coach of LSU say if if he'd
known what was going on right now and
obviously there's lots more to go but
what would what's happening hard work
hard work dedication believe it allured
and good things happen okay and what do
you do for your voice coach I mean what
are you done done it's natural you know
I've always had this voices it's a voice
that's helped me out of my coaching my
defensive line it's a natural thing ya
know so tea with honey I mean what do
you do do you do anything to support
everyone sort of awesome Epson so
gargling salt without water one mama
when I get the horse in the encampment
hmm in camp so you don't usually do that
you're in the regular season what you're
saying no I don't get hoarse during the
regular season I gotta be honest with
you it sounds you know right now so this
is this is normal so you're fine throat
doesn't hurt you're fine you're feeling
good feeling good cuz you've got one of
the toughest schedules in the United
States of America coach I mean that is
something you know you've got to deal
with yeah yeah I support being LSU you
know something we accept again we take
it a one day at a time we focus in on
Louisiana Tech we train all right now
we're happy to be three and old our goal
is to be four know at the end of
Saturday night that's all we can control
and there's a ton of guys at the next
level who were rooting for you they were
all LSU Tigers who'd you hear from after
the game you know obviously the Twitter
was blown up guys like Patrick Peterson
Odell Beckham Jarvis Landry
Lyle Collins all the great ones are very
proud of the whole LSU Tiger team hi
Matthew - he sees he's always out there
- no question coach appreciate the time
thanks very much we'll chat again real
soon okay and you take you take care of
yourself go Tigers you got it as a doors
rock the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience